language immersion it's a term we hear
all the time in connection with learning
languages I've talked a bit about it
before I want to talk about it now with
reference to my recent visit to Poland
so
you know we have language immersion
programs in school my grandchildren here
in Vancouver did all their schooling in
French so they are immersed in French
the teacher speaks in French all the
subjects are covered in French
as a result of that they get a fairly
high level of comprehension their
speaking ability isn't necessarily all
that great however it is ready to be
activated at any time because they have
been immersed in the language they have
good comprehension they have learned
many subjects using French that's one
form of immersion
you also hear people say you know to you
have to to learn the language you need
to immerse yourself in the language it's
a good image you kind of get into the
pool you get wet you're sort of drowning
in the language you're immersed in the
language
but what does it really mean uh
obviously if you go to a country where
you can't speak the language or you've
had or you have a very limited knowledge
of the language it's very difficult to
be immersed in the language
you are surrounded by the language
you're surrounded by people who speak
the language you may hear the language
on radio or television
but you're not really connected to the
language you're not participating in the
language and so many people can live in
a country where a language is spoken and
if they don't put any effort into
learning the language being there alone
being immersed in the language is not
going to do much for them
by the same token you can immerse
yourself in the language without being
in the country where the language is
spoken you can read you can listen you
can talk to people online you can create
sort of a language world for yourself
which is also a form of immersion
now how does all that relate to my visit
to Poland
so I came back I was in Poland for I
guess six or seven days really enjoyed
it I enjoyed discovering Poland
uh my wife and I flew first to Warsaw
then turned around and the next day went
to Copenhagen that's just the way our
ticket was structured and then we worked
our way back to Poland through Sweden
and basically from the evening of the
25th until the you know midday of the
second of June we were in Poland half of
the time roughly spent in Warsaw half of
it spent in Krakow
which is one of the historical capitals
of Poland now since I was there with my
wife mostly we were speaking English my
attempts at speaking polish despite
having spent two months prior to going
you know listening to a lot of Polish
reading a lot of Polish I had one italki
lesson before going
uh that's not
real immersion but it's a start towards
immersing myself in the language
uh eight years ago I had a program of
three months where I did the same
so and I had committed to doing two
interviews in Polish
when in Poland and these took place in
uh Krakow
so prior to going I had attempted to use
my polish on the flight going over with
taxi drivers with very limited success I
was very much aware of my limitations
and yet
arriving in Krakow on the 29th I had an
interview entirely in Polish for easy
polish a website I'll leave a link in
the description box
I am in fact following up with them to
see if I can get at least a part of that
interview and put it up here on my
channel so you can see me struggling in
a combination of Slavic languages lots
of mistakes however communicating
so the important thing there is that for
I think was 10 or 15 minutes maybe live
longer I was communicating in Polish so
I was hearing polish I was hearing
polish having to do with the subject
that we were discussing
and so therefore that input is very
relevant to me it's what I call very
high resonance because I'm very much
involved in it I can't be wandering my
attention can't be wandering somewhere
else I have to pay attention to what
people are saying so I'm getting that
input I'm making mistakes while speaking
um aware of some of the mistakes as I'm
making them if I see a video of the
interview I will be aware of more
mistakes that I make and all of this it
does kind of nudge me in the direction
of speaking better because I start to
notice things in the language maybe I'm
you know I'm aware of many rules that I
can't really apply on the Fly
but then I notice when I see myself in a
video that I made this or that mistake I
know it's a mistake but In the Heat of
the Moment speaking I couldn't produce
the language correctly but that is a
form of of immersion
uh the next day I had another interview
uh with a gentleman
who is a motivational speaker in Poland
he does these interviews in his Bentley
which is his Studio we drive around the
city and he asks me questions and we
spoke in a number of languages including
polish and that will also go up on his
channel I will at some point make you
aware of where that
you know where you can see that again I
struggled in my polish I struggled in
some of the other languages again it's a
form of immersion even if you're doing
poorly it's a form of immersion because
you are involved in speaking with
someone but I think also like on my way
back first of all we had a meet up in
Warsaw and one of the attendants was an
American will who lives in Gdansk and he
gave me this book
which is a
story told by someone describing life in
Poland before the outbreak of the second
World War
and very kind of well he came down from
gedansk and he even wrote a little you
know uh dedication message here thanking
me for the influence that I have had on
his attitude towards language learning a
very positive person is well and I thank
him very much for the book I picked up a
lot of books in Poland I can never
resist going to bookstores I bought a
bunch of books my language luggage was
much heavier going back I've also found
audiobooks and eBooks on history from
public
dot PL which I've imported in the link
and I've been reading them I also did
find the digital version of this book
and so I've been doing that on link
alternating between reading it online
and reading it on paper
uh this book I couldn't find any digital
version of it but I read the whole thing
on the plane
coming back and I've often said that
when you read a a paper book away from
the internet the whole book The your
first book is like a major milestone in
the language so all of the things that
and to me this is a form of of immersion
uh it takes a long time for this passive
vocabulary to to crystallize to activate
to where you're actually able to use
this and you do eventually have to put
yourself into situations where you're
using these words all the time
but you are really building up your
capability you're developing your
comprehension it is a form of immersion
just like uh kids like my grandchildren
in French immersion in Canada it's
mostly passive it's mostly hearing the
language it's mostly learning things
through the language but I also consider
that a form of immersion uh it's just
simply not practical always to speak
speaking is one form of immersion
largely because of the input that you
get back but listening and reading is
also immersion visiting Poland seeing
Krakow interacting even in a limited way
with Polish people seeing how they live
eating their food getting a sense of
their history traveling in the country
traveling on their trains uh having a
coffee on the Square in Krakow all of
these things are immersing you in the
language the culture the history the
environment of the language it's all
part of immersion so immersion is not
just sitting down with someone and
speaking immersion is getting involved
with everything that relates to that
language building up your passive
capability which is going to form the
base then for your active capability so
I think the definition of immersion
should be much broader than just going
to a country and assuming you can start
speaking to people you can't there's so
many things so many ways you can immerse
yourself in the language before going so
that when you do go there you can get
greater Advantage from the potential
immersion opportunities that are there I
am determined to continue with my
reading and passive immersion activities
on link where I have a number of books
on uh polish history and it's good to do
something like history using different
resources just like with the language
you want to cover the same ground using
different resources and I think
that already now I think my capability
to speak would be better than it was
when I arrived in Krakow and if I give
myself another few weeks here with
Polish history and and other resources
like this book here which I have both on
link to look up the words and reading it
on paper to have a different kind of
experience
um I think my capability will improve
and I will try to schedule a discussion
another discussion in Polish in two
weeks to a month as I continue along in
my
immersion program in Polish and the
final thing was I was very surprised by
Poland very positive country
energetic people a lot of things worked
very well many people out on the streets
in the evenings enjoying themselves we
had a great time
thank you for listening bye for now